welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day two and
we're gonna learn the wealth habits of
billionaires enjoy
[Music]
there are a lot of things that are a
waste of time you know when you think
about your life
i think i i often tell people um that i
work with
if you can get because people people
have very high standards for
how they want their work life to be and
uh and i said look if you can get your
work life
to be where you enjoy half of it that is
a home
that is amazing because very few people
ever achieve
that because the truth is everything
comes with overhead
that's reality everything comes with
pieces that you don't like
you could be a supreme court justice and
there's still going to be pieces of your
job you don't like
you can be a university professor and
it's still going to be
you have to go to committee meetings and
you have to do you know
there are every job comes with pieces
you don't like
and we need to say that's just how
that's part of it
and and not resent those pieces or try
not to
but also try to minimize them i tell
senior executives
you should have the least stress you
know there's this weird
i think false idea
that ceos i'm a ceo there's this false
idea that ceos are under the most stress
well i look at that i'm like why you're
in charge
why don't you delegate the stress it's
your choice
and uh so it's you have to figure out
how to
set up your life in such a way that you
can minimize the things
and i find people don't dislike hard
work
what people dislike and what is being
out of control like they can't control
their life they can't control their
environment
this happens to me when i get over
scheduled
i hate being over scheduled i want some
time
to be able to think and free myself we
all have the same amount of time in the
world
nobody has more time than anybody else
and when you become a very successful
person
one of the things you start to get over
scheduled
you have this event you had to agree to
do this and maybe last night you were
like
why did i agree to do this i have to go
on stage tomorrow
i wish i were really with my family and
you know or i hope maybe not this case
let's say that you like this one but in
general
that kind of thing happens and so you
have to guard your time
and and and try to say a little bit
flexible
so that's for me it's not a waste of
time but i like
to have some freedom of movement
rather than having every minute of every
day
scheduled by far the best investment you
can make is in yourself
i mean that for example communication
skills i tell the students that come
that they're going to graduate schools
and
business and they're learning all these
complicated formulas all that
if they just learn to communicate better
and both in writing and
in person they increase their value at
least 50 percent and now i mean
if you can't communicate somebody who
says you know it's like winking at a
girl in the dark
nothing happens you know basically and
and you have to be able to get
get both your ideas and uh and that's
that's relatively easy i did it myself
with the dale carnegie of course
some people wish i'd taken a shorter
course now in terms of my talking later
on
but it it's just hugely important and
you if you invest in yourself
nobody can take it away from you
certainly uh being focused on something
that you're confident will have high
value to someone else
and just being really rigorous in making
that assessment
because people are attend tend to a
natural human tendency is wishful
thinking
um so a challenge for entrepreneurs is
to say well what's the difference
between
really believing in your ideals and
sticking sticking to them
versus pursuing some unrealistic dream
that
doesn't actually have merit and it's
it's that is a that is a really
difficult thing to
to tell you can you tell the difference
between those two things right so you
need to be sort of
very rigorous um in your self self
analysis
um i think certainly extremely tenacious
uh and um and then just
work like hell i mean you just have to
put in
you know 80 hour 80 to 100 hour weeks
every
week because
and then a lot of work that that all
those things improve the odds of success
okay um i mean if if other people are
putting in 40 hour work weeks and you're
putting in
100 hour work weeks then even if
you're doing the same thing you know
that in in one year you will achieve
what they achieve
you will achieve in four months what it
takes them
a year to achieve i feel like hustle is
the willingness to work really really
hard and then also
your willingness to get the job done
like
um kind of navigating and doing what it
takes
and um and so
i i yeah i've there's so much about my
journey where i was like i am not going
to let the
outcome or my success be contingent
on other people as much as i can control
it
help it navigate it i'm going to so
um so yeah in the beginning
especially still now i mean obviously
i'm hustling i'm like at the
at this where i am now and i'm running
around the airport asking people to
follow me on instagram
you know i just feel like it's innate in
me also
to a degree um but
the uh in the beginning ex like there's
a few examples that come to mind
you mentioned that i paid my i called my
friends and asked them to go
buy spanx and i wrote everybody checks
and sent them a check
um because i needed to drive momentum
and i had no money to advertise so i'm
like this product is going to sit on the
shelf so i need to to get
people to go in and buy it i also when i
went into the stores i realized very
quickly that
my product was in the sleepiest part of
the department store it was back in the
corner and nobody was going there
so then i immediately
went to target and i bought
um envelope dividing dividers that you
put on your home desk
and i ran around neiman marcus and put
them at every register
and i put spanx in them and then i
walked away
and neiman's has like impeccable visual
rules and regulations and um and i did
that because i had to get my product out
of the department and because i did that
women in
shoes started buying spanx and women in
contemporary and
and um those decisions made such a big
difference and
by the time somebody figured out that
nobody else had approved it
because i you know everybody thought
somebody else approved it um
it was so successful that the head of
neiman's was like whatever this girl's
doing let her keep doing it
i mean the balance of work and play is
critical
and i think a lot of people don't get
that balance right you know i'm 63 years
old now
so critical to find time for yourself
get out there and keep fit and and i
find the best way of keeping fit is by
playing
i try to encourage our chief executives
worldwide to make sure that there's as
much flexibility
in in the workplace as possible we've
set up something called the b
team which is examining the way
companies treat their staff
and trying to make suggestions to make
the dignity of work better than it's
been in the past
if you're too close to a situation you
know like in an office
you get bogged down with the manuta if
you can step away from the situation
you can think about the bigger picture
and that's what i'm able to do on there
the most extraordinary people come to
necca the elders was conceived here on
necker with archbishop tutu with
president carter with kofi annan
the carbon wall room was conceived here
an organization that tries to work with
industry to try to
extract carbon out of the earth's
atmosphere you know sitting
in muhammad looking up at the stars at
night things like virgin galactic
so great place to think and a great
place to conceive ideas
well we had a fantastic day it was a
sunday so it wasn't all work
so a great way of capping off the day
watch the super bowl
with a cup of tea and uh
today the 18 founders of alibaba
a lot of people think they are
legendaries i mean wow you all hibaba
founders you must be
super good at honestly most of us cannot
find the jobs early days
we're not that smart none of us graduate
from a
you know a great university um
but the thing is that we are ready to
learn
we believing in the future if we work
together if we will learn with improve
we'll be there i told them for the first
year everybody forget about
that you will be vp vice president right
you will always be a tiny manager in
your life
because if we're successful people will
hide they will be smarter than us
if we only hire people who are stupid
than us then we'll be in trouble
right so when we hire people who are
smarter than us the company will grow
and you will be happy because this is
the mission that we have
so i will say there's no best
people in the world that is suit ready
for you
the best of people is always you you
find the right people
working together training him developing
him and
he training you he then you have a
chance to build a team
grant rant of the day the one you need
to live with wake up to every day
is that right there okay
beat the sun up folks you got to beat
the sun up if you can't beat up the roll
up of the sun up
you're going gonna get beat up in life
okay i've been doing this for a long
time now
say beat that thing up that monster out
there that warms this planet
that nourishes and gives us light
i can see again i can't see in the dark
for some reason because i don't practice
seeing in the dark most the time i'm on
my back
when it's dark look i'm at singapore
today
okay i get on this side of the building
the views on that side are ridiculous
the views on this side are crazy
ridiculous and i'm living
the 10x life but you can't live a 10x
life if you're not beating the sun up
so many of you complain about how much
time you have you don't have time man
because you don't beat the sun up get
started early
and when you get started early that
means you need to shut it down early
okay shut it down early so you get sleep
i was
i was asleep last night at nine o'clock
so i could beat the sun up tomorrow this
morning and see
the world wake up with me look at it
dude
look at it my friends my folks my my
beat the sun up people my 10xers out
there
check this out these are all boats
waiting to dump oil and supplies into
singapore and make some money
while you sleeping they hunting
somebody's looking all the time
so i want you to try this for the next
let's just say 30 days 30 days beat the
damn sun up beat it up man
it just rolls over you just roll over
and beat it up
before it gets up hope this finds you
well beat the sun up
facebook instagram twitter snapchat
uh linkedin
i probably posted about this event more
than the entire room combined
today in addition to all the other stuff
i'm doing how many old people here let
me see your hand if you consider
yourself an old person
okay thank you thanks sir appreciate it
you're like dude it's just kind of like
i didn't do it i'm 61 years old man
[Music]
i'm 61 years old and and i'm banging on
these mechanisms because they're gifts
they're gifts they're gifts from the
gods
if you have a great service and a great
great product and you have a great
company raise your hand if you have
those three things
do you got to tell the world okay
because this
the the cycle the business cycle your
business survivability
okay your business success is dependent
upon
first marketing wow i can't do it i
don't have the money it's because your
goals are wrong
you're not going to pay for the
marketing and advertising who's going to
pay for it
the guy that paid for the 15 000 package
what's the roi what is the roi on
nothing
[Music]
okay what's your return on investment
every i grew up in the roi school okay i
have 14 businesses today
started four of them in the last 60 days
okay i i want expansion what
is the roi
this is the business consultant i need
to see the roi dude i don't i don't do
rois on
any of my businesses
i make a decision is it a good business
decision
do people need to know who i am okay i
have never studied
the return on an ad that i did on
youtube
or facebook or instagram or cnbc
i don't need a return i need people to
know me
okay you guys need to switch this thing
you need to switch it how many have cash
in the bank let me see
hands if you have cash in the bank good
good then you're not committed to your
business to the degree that you have
cash in the bank
how many do you have equity in your
homes let me see a hand if you have
equity in your house raise your damn
hands
y'all proud of it okay if to the degree
that you have
equity in your house you are not
committed to your business
and you will never take big pharma down
dude you need that money to fight the
war
i don't i don't have equity in a house
okay
i have equity in my business okay
i get cash i put it in my business
i get more cash i put it in more
business right i put it in people
knowing me because if they don't know me
who's going to win the war whoever's
best known wins
best product never wins you want to
write this down best product never wins
never has one never will win
best known always wins see this is the
problem i had
as a young salesman dude i was like okay
i'm gonna make 80 grand a year
it isn't worth it like like
like if i make 80 grand a year as a
salesman
i'm making 7 dollars a month and i live
in miami
you're not going to do it changes
nothing the
opportunity has to change your life
significantly enough
that you're willing to read study dive
in right
you add a zero to that right there you
had a zero to that eighty
now i'm willing to learn every human
being is like this by the way
every human being on this planet maybe
i'm wrong tell me if i'm wrong comment
please
i add a zero to that you're going to do
stuff that you wouldn't have done
just a moment befo ago okay if i can
show you how to
how to go from 80 000 to 800 000
all of a sudden your creativity you like
i think i just met
van gogh god damn i got some madonna
coming out of my butt
okay whoa whoa whoa
i got music in my head like like ding
ding ding ding you like
because why man because yeah maybe the
glass underneath my feet don't hurt so
bad
right because why because the goal is
big enough most people do not have
goals that will change their lives
therefore they cannot
lean into the opportunity hard enough
for those of you who own businesses
you need to create rings in your
business
okay so that natalie can see hey man i
can go outside this
these i can go outside these rings and
there's more opportunity out here for
financial freedom or
she stays right here and she doesn't
resent me she resents her
because i keep throwing them out here
i'm like hey there's a 20 000 product
you can sell right here
there's a five thousand dollar product
you can get benefit from here oh by the
way there's a million dollars out here
if you want to
in people's lives you have distractions
and you have opportunities to go do
other stuff and look at other stuff
[Applause]
you know it's like in indecisi
indecisiveness
is the weakness as you wear so well
and it's like look you guys want to be
you want to be hoodwinked by the covid
you want to be
hijacked by the election you want to be
uh thrown off because of somebody's uh
comments about you like the the universe
will
send you endless
numbers of distractions and and to
to people that are fully completely
committed
they're like yeah i saw that happen yeah
i heard there was a car wreck over there
guys sent me something this morning
uh on from fox news about this guy that
was arrested i'm like why are you
passing this on to me
and i said do not never pass on bad
information to me i don't need it i
don't want it i'm not interested in it
by the way you're better than that
and all the people you know the people
you know don't need that message
and at the same time by the way he sent
it to a friend of mine another friend of
mine my wife got it
but nobody said stop it hey guys hey
guys
papa's on a podcast sorry about that so
again you see that like like stop the
distraction stop the noise
and and if you don't say no to it it
will continue
uh it will feed you to be distracted and
give you excuses to not achieve the
things that you're capable of
do not try
the competition thing it's overrated and
it doesn't work and i'm going to prove
it to you right here in a second
okay this is a private what's called an
fbo
everybody that flies in here owns their
own aircraft
[Music]
you don't want to try to be the biggest
jet okay
you don't want to try to beat up most
money you don't want to try to be the
like the best of the best there'll
always be somebody faster
and stronger and richer okay don't play
the game
oh i gotta be number one what does that
even mean man
i gotta be the biggest what does that
even mean i gotta have the biggest car
the biggest watch the hottest
chick what does that mean
it's a game you cannot win at okay you
will get your brains
handed to you i'm gonna show you what i
mean right here in a second that's
laying right there
that's a little learjet right there i
think it's a little leer of phenom i
don't have all my jets right
i don't know you can buy that plane for
about 800 grand
right next to it a little bigger
look what's rolling up right here a
little challenger
we got a little gulfstream 4 right there
that's leaks 13. don't try to play the
game
i'm the biggest that's stupid it's a
stupid game
okay it's a loser's game man
i'm going to show you some equipment out
here because anybody like here's a
little phenom 100
that plays about 5 million bucks great
playing faster
fast so fast seat seven people okay
maybe four or five million bucks great
plane great starter plane
look at this see that right out there
that's a 20 passenger jet right there
okay now notice what's right next to it
john
okay that's a 727 that a hotel owned
if you try to play that game the
competition game
i'm the strongest i'm the best you lose
that game
you got to find what you need in life
what's enough for you you guys got to
define that
i can't define it for you most people
are coming up short on that game
but there's a lot of other people that
are making the mistake when they get in
the game and they start playing
they got to keep reaching not because
they need it
but because their ego is like oh i got
to be the biggest
and you know what you are you're going
to turn into
a hotel owns that that plane's probably
200 million dollars back there
the point is don't play i gotta be the
strongest
because sooner or later you won't be
find out what you need look look look
the ass on that plane over there hey
look at my little plane look at my
little plane
see you're like man grant man man your
little
no no no flash over to this one
see if i'm doing the comparison thing
the competition thing
it's a loser's game what do you think
it'll take for you to get over
insecurity moving forward
i'm not trying you're not trying it's
not trying to i thought you said if you
could get rid of it you'd be able to do
bigger
the unbelievable but but it's not it's
not it's not a target i have
letting go of insecurity no i think it's
just a human condition i think it's part
of the game i think it's part of
being a human being any more than i want
to get rid of my arms
you know or my legs or my arms and my
legs my body
my body is a limitation yeah you know so
um how do you manage it better than like
for people that are saying
i you know i want a 10x but i always
have insecurity and fear
that i'm going to fail and people are
going to show up and yeah the deal's
going to i'm going to go broke
how do you personally get tell the
conversation to yourself
to the insecurity and fear yeah it's not
stop it's come
you know for me for me fear fear the
things i i'm scared of i'm like
come on you know it's calling me says
hey come play over here
it's an indicator it's a good indicator
not a bad indicator lean into it
lean into it come play with me okay so i
either have fear because it's really
dangerous
and stupid or like physically dangerous
yeah like let me get to the edge of this
thing i'm gonna get on the other side of
that thing i'm probably gonna be scared
yeah now why am i gonna be scared though
like
because i don't know what it feels like
to fall you know this many floors and
hit
yeah maybe it does maybe there's no big
deal about maybe dying is not even a big
deal right
but i don't have the exp i don't
consciously have the experience
so you know i used to be like
i can't buy a 78 000 house i was
terrified the first house i bought
i don't know what i'm doing because you
have experience i don't have the
experience man
this this is the problem and you're not
going to have the experience if you
don't move through the fear
and a lot of people do it once and then
they don't do it again you got
like it's not going away yeah it's just
gonna
you're gonna get used to you're gonna
get used to the ski boots
you know the first time you put them on
man they're freaking banging your shins
like i can't mend but you just wear into
them
the theme that runs in my life is just
disappointment throughout the whole
thing
particularly the first from fifth to
from 10 years old to 25
and then 25 to 50
you know yeah i was doing better because
i i had a drug problem at
16. oh you did yeah was that the
disappointment or was it like no no no
the drugs were just the drugs were a
byproduct you know it was
the disappointment was uh you know
the school thing school was
disappointing no uncles no dad
right no i didn't know direction just
boredom
that's why what you do with these the
races at least keep somebody
occupied for some moment of time that
gives them a goal big enough and a
challenge
sure i didn't have any challenges you
didn't have anybody like setting some
goals up in front of us
no no no when my dad died i kept waiting
for one of the uncles to step up and
they didn't
god and that pissed me off because i'm
like dude somebody's got to step up and
give me a little guidance here
but you but you had older um brothers my
older brother died when i was 20. right
so
10 years after my dad died so there was
no men
just a bunch of women and mom mom wasn't
like setting big goals for you
no no my mom my mom grew up in bread
lunch
so you know i'd go to my mom i remember
i did a deal when i was 30.
i bought my first piece of real estate
and um
mom i bought this piece of real estate
it was three million dollars
a 1.9 million dollars and she's like wow
that's great but you know i just i love
you just the way you are
right and i hung up the phone she said
that to me a thousand times
and i hung the phone and said yeah but i
don't love me the way i am
and then my counselor buddy dale says
you need to love yourself
the way you are i said ain't never going
to happen dude
right i said that's the big lot i don't
want to love me in the way
i want to become the guy i should be i
just want to share a couple things with
you
about creating wealth this is not
something i was taught
this is something i discovered through
trial and error
through finally becoming aware that what
i was being taught didn't work
um look i was brought up
like most of you watching this if you're
if you were brought up poor
in the middle class you were never
ever exposed to possibilities and
opportunities
you were trained to get an education
work hard
get a job that's my buddy jj right
behind me
he's in transition in his life 50 years
old getting ready to make a move
getting ready to do something different
see him putting his tongue out here's my
little girl right here
this is what i'm talking about wealth
well real wealth
real wealth would include the freedom to
go where you want
when you want stay as long as you want
and you deserve that okay you deserve it
listen to what i'm telling you right now
because
everybody told me i couldn't have what i
was dreaming of
everybody told me it's not possible give
it up
that's only for select people you got to
have a big break to make that happen
you're thinking ridiculous don't have
high expectations
well the truth is my entire life i've
had monster
monster expectations and again i want to
remind you when i talk about wealth
creation fund i'm not talking about
money
okay yes early money would include but
i'm talking about family i'm talking
about
love i'm talking about marriage i'm
talking about
kids man
i'm talking about having the life you
want going where you want doing what you
want
wealth creation formula listen to what
i'm saying to you if you pay attention
to this
if this message is getting you at that
time in your life where you're like you
know what
i'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired
i know there's something wrong with what
people are telling me
your mom and dad got a job bought a home
put some money in retirement and they're
worried every second
of every day that is not wealth okay
that is not
freedom most of you watching this are
going to be in the united states
but if you're outside the united states
see if you're outside the united states
you want to be
you want to be have a middle class like
the united states
if you're in the united states and
you're in the middle class
you're like wait a minute what what is
this thing the middle class
and why am i not feeling the freedom
that everybody says this should be so
good
i got a good job maybe it's paying you
50 grand or 60 grand or 70 grand or 200
grand
the truth is in all of those levels you
know
there's no freedom there's no wealth if
you look up the word wealth
it might be a good thing for you to do
here i'm going to give you a couple of
tips and i'm going to give you this link
to a wealth creation formula that i did
literally discovered that i wrote the
blueprint for you to have
a formula so you could create wealth
so you could create what you want in
your life
so you can go where you want get your
family with you if you want
hopefully you want to take your family
with you
so what is this is it possible
is it possible for you to have a plane
with your name on it 365 gc
is the tail is on that back engine right
there
called the tail number and that tail
number it says
i'm going to be grant cardone 365 days
of the year that little plane right
there is 8.3 million dollars to buy it
used
costs 2 million dollars a year to
operate
how do you do that when you grew up
broke
you grew up poor i'm talking broke i'm
talking every week
your paycheck goes to your bills it goes
to your rent for the first
from between the ages of 19 and 23
or 25 19 to 25 i couldn't make my rent
for six years and then one day i'm like
i'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired
okay how do i create wealth how do i
create freedom how do i get enough money
and it's tough it's tough when
everybody's telling you you can't do it
you see what i'm saying my mom and dad
nobody talked to me about having your
own brain
nobody talked to you about millions of
dollars but it's possible
it's possible and you should have it
look if i can do this you can do this
all right
but i couldn't do it because i was
operating with other people's formulas
that were based on jobs and salaries and
retirements
and savings and cutting and pinching
and save the pennies and save the
nickels
and put the money in the keo account
because my employer will match and i
never get that money for 30 years
look that right there that is real
wealth
that is real wealth that allows me i'm
not talking about money again i'm
talking about real wealth that allows me
to go where i want
when i want how i want so here i'm going
to give you a couple things the first
thing the first thing on the wealth
creation formula
and this might seem really simple and
dumb to you but do you need income
you need income you guys out there
hating on jobs
you're like oh man a job job is just
above broke you need a job that pays you
money
okay the second thing you need to do is
you need to get that money
and only only only spend money
only spend money on things
that will create more income you
understand what i'm saying
no debt no debt
debt is not for spending
debt is not for a home i would never
borrow money
to buy a home we rent our house okay we
rent we just
we just left a vacation for 10 days i
rented a guy's 13 million
13 million dollar house oh it's nice too
got a beautiful house i don't want to
own his house i want to rent his house i
want to use his house
me and my wife grabbed his house put our
kids in it and we walk away when we want
okay
but tell them why we wouldn't want a
second vacation home did you already do
that yeah
about then you're stuck going to the
same place
you already already went over there oh
what are you doing barefooted huh
she doesn't know i'm going to give you
all this material in the wealth creation
whoa okay go what you where you want do
what you want
stay as long as you want we were going
to go extend our vacation for another
seven days or so
but we can't because mama didn't bring
the passport
mama didn't bring the passport so you
know what now we don't have our freedom
again
so we'll go to miami and pick them up
and who knows maybe sabrina will talk me
into going another place
so look here's the deal in the link
below since my family's grabbing me now
i want you to grab i want you to get the
link to the
wealth creation formulas this is not
something i was taught
this is something i discovered from the
age of 25
25 to about 45 i started my companies
thank you i started companies
and i did it all wrong okay and i want
you to learn from my mistakes so you
don't have to
make the same mistakes first thing i did
wrong was when i made money i spent it
okay i spent it on junk and i'm like i
corrected that really quick because
that was fine i i've always been a
fairly frugal person
believe it or not i'm telling you about
a plane about i'm telling you about a
vacation where we just
spent 10 days in the past 13 million
house but i'm actually extremely frugal
i've always been frugal but the problem
with the frugal is at some point the
frugal traps you and contracts you
and makes you stay smaller than you need
to be i should have been reinvesting
money
so this is what you're going to learn in
the wealth creation formula first thing
you got to do is make money second thing
you got to do is add income to that i
know that
sounds simple but you're missing some
points and i'll go into detail on it
the third thing you want to do is you
want to stay broke
now this is a very very important
concept this is the concept that allowed
me to buy this plane actually i bought
this plane two years ago
based on the concept of going broke make
money
create second flows of income multiple
flows of income
to start trapping more money and when
you start
accelerating that and getting more money
and savings you want to go broke you
want to start investing
in things that will allow you to buy
time and opportunity okay time and
opportunity are worth way more than
money
and again you'll see all this
information in the wealth creation
department and you might be thinking
dude this guy's just bragging about how
much money he makes no i'm not okay
okay don't be envious envy is not a way
to increase
your wealth your time your freedom or
increase the value of your family okay
the way the way the way for you to get
out of the trap
the trap that i watch my mom my dad my
brothers my sisters so many of my
friends
the way to get out of that trap so i got
a buddy here jj
he came out we're flying him home i had
three of my other employees out here my
executive employees
brought my kids out this is this is a
guy i can't tell you who that dude is
in the door in the gateway there what is
it called
the plane goes up
so much going on man there's so much
going on so look look check it out
okay here's the deal the reason i'm
telling you this is not to brag
if i can do this you can do this okay if
i can do this you can do this but you
need the right information
and by the way let me just say this for
you for those of you watching this and
like
i don't need all that stuff i don't need
a plane you need a vacation don't you
you need to bring your kids on that damn
vacation maybe you need two or three
vacations a year
okay how about this how about you don't
need a vacation but you need to stop
worrying every second of every day every
minute
see i watched my mom worry from the age
of
i guess she was 48 years old when did
she have me
my mom had me when she was 38 my dad
died 10 years later
so my mom's 48 years old has no income
and no ability
to have a job no didn't know how to
create multiple flows of income
didn't know what to invest money in
never thought about
time and freedom
as more important than money so what
happened she just tried to save her way
and save the family to take care of us
that is not a way to take care of a
family the way to take care of your
family is to create time
and opportunity and you're going to hear
and you're going to see in detail
me walk through each of the steps in the
wealth creation formula
because you deserve that folks maybe you
don't want to fly friday okay
no problem just take the money and give
it to a church take it and give it to
you
to people that are suffering hurt okay
or maybe do you do this you buy the
plane
you create more time and more
opportunities and that creates more
money
so you can get to more charities the
church help your neighborhood help your
family
all i'm telling you is this okay
you deserve it you deserve to have it
all
you deserve to go where you want do what
you want
have a little bed for the kids so they
can sleep on the way home
okay you deserve this life okay
and by the way when you get this i
guarantee you you you you
you only have to do one thing you got to
pay taxes
i'll talk a little bit about that in the
wealth creation plan how to how to
minimize that see people in the middle
class
and even rich people they get they get
hammered so hard by taxes because they
never learn
how to avoid legally how to take
advantage
of the tax trap see those guys can be
beat
but to do that you got to have cash flow
again it's in the link below okay i'm
trying to inspire you right now to say
look
you deserve it all you deserve this
lifestyle you deserve what i'm doing
right now
you deserve it you should have it you
should have it for yourself
your spouse your kids your family
okay you deserve to have it all
we're gonna go to miami now there's a
there's a tail cam and a map if i switch
this over
let me see if i can show you how to
switch over
forward video
i'm gonna show you the tunnel cam watch
look this is the tail cam
see there's the mountains that's where i
was outside i was walking around out
here
is that cool or what
okay i'm done bragging i'm done bragging
but i'm not really right you got to give
me a what 30 minutes massage
what you want to earn 18 really bad
don't you
yes first step in the wealth creation
formula
how do you find the right job to create
the right income i'll actually lay that
out for you
how do you find the right job the right
vehicle to create the right amount of
income at the right time and opportunity
number two how do you add multiple flows
of income
okay what do you spend money on what not
to spend money on when to use debt when
not to use
debt okay third thing how do you go
broke
on purpose why do you go broke on
purpose
this is a phenomenal thing that i've
done for years now i discovered this
what you need my seat to go down
why so it can be a massage oh so it can
be a massage she wants to give me a
massage turn some income
then you go broke now she's gonna go
broke on some shopkins
i wouldn't advise that i would go broken
investments i would pour that money into
things that create new flows of income
it said that the average millionaire has
seven flows of income
it's actually way higher than that
imagine 25 years old i'm broke got a
drug problem
today i probably have 70 different flows
of income
okay half of which are more passive than
active
it's a life man it's a good life tell
you what's a long way from being broke
in a drug problem
long way from not having the wife i want
not having the kids i want
not having the time freedom i wanted
you deserve that they don't teach it in
school they don't teach you in college
your mom and dad probably didn't know
how to do it
okay number one
you can have this life number two
you deserve this life number three
if i can help you get there then you
help me fulfill my legacy
number four i asked one thing of you
when you make it and you will
if i can you can okay when you make it i
ask you to do one thing
pay attention to what you're doing pay
attention to what works write it down
build a program and give it away to
other people
i remember having a job i remember like
i'm making
60 grand a year and i cannot figure out
how to have any money left over
there was never money left over it
didn't matter how hard i worked how good
i got at it i
i i said i was making 30 figured out how
to get to 60 and didn't have anything
trading time for prison
people talk about slavery i was a slave
i was sitting there man i could not get
off the treadmill
[Music]
so tonight i want to talk to you not
about making money
okay yeah you need to make money but
you're already making money everybody in
the room's making money how many made
some money today
somebody gave you something for your
time today making money is not your
issue
you already make money okay and you
already want to do better
you need to have the right target okay
the target i'm gonna do this in black
okay the target is freedom
all energy all investments
should be going toward freedom not money
money by itself is a trap it's useless
pieces of paper
there's no passion in it who's got a
hundred on them
my wife race raises her hand i got a
bunch of your money with me
okay who's got 100 on her okay let me
see 100.
i want to see if your money's any
different than my money
this is yeah see i just made 100.
okay it's a little more than that 20 40
60 80
100 120 140 160 180
white people okay 195 i got 195. okay
go ahead and sit down sir please see
it's easy to make money
right all you got to do all you got to
do is understand
understand money i don't need to
actually manufacture money
so when i ask you guys how many of you
want to make more money you're like
you don't need to unnecessary step
okay you want to write this down
strangers have
everything you want everything you want
is in the hands of a stranger
your mama don't have it your daddy don't
have it
your uncle doesn't it uncle g might have
it okay uh uh your nieces don't have it
the money that you want the freedom you
desire
is in the hands the bank accounts the
real estate the companies
of people you don't even know
i don't need to make money this is what
you guys going to work every day i got
to make money i got to make money wrong
target
wrong target i need to connect with
people that can get me to freedom
this by itself is passionless there is
no passion in it it's pieces of paper
it was printed by a machine okay
somebody decided
okay on this one we're going to put abe
we're going to put
andrew jackson on this one we're going
to put
they're all andrews i hadn't seen this
many 20s in a long time
okay so it says because i don't keep 20s
i'm like give those so give those to the
guy
park in the car you guys should keep 20s
just to pass them out to other people
say here
get rid of little little babies
[Music]
get rid of the little babies and make
friends use use andrew jackson
to get your freedom i'm gonna go free no
excuses anymore no education reasons no
economic reasons i don't care who the
president is or who he is
i'm getting my freedom okay if you're
taking notes tonight
i'm not interested in inspiration i'm
not trying to get you jacked up tonight
how many of you jacked up already like
i'm already jacked up
i want to get jacked up i go to
starbucks i get jacked up cost me four
bucks to get stuck i get joe
i'm jacked up i need freedom who wants
freedom
freedom should become your battle cry
okay
since 25 years old the only thing i've
been interested in was
being me on my terms
i was talking to deion sanders just
three nights ago
dion hits me because my instagram feeds
like man how can i help you all know who
dion is
deion sanders i said deion sanders good
dude right there good dude
he hits a little guy from lake charles
louisiana nobody knows i hadn't been in
a world series hadn't been in a football
game
i can't do any of that stuff i'm not a
rapper i'm not famous
he hits me and says how can i help you
do what you do i said well i said well
dion what do you think i do he's like
you do a lot of stuff man i said but
what do you think i do dion
he's like well well you you you're an
honest guy you're a truthful person it
appears to want to help a lot of people
and i said i do man i said tell i tell
you what i want to do because people
know that i've written books i've
written eight books
13 best-selling business programs that
have made millions and millions of
dollars for me and my family and my
companies
we have we have 14 little divisions of
companies right here in aventura
about five miles from here uh that
that'll do 150 million dollars this year
and i remember when i was 23 years old i
couldn't pay 275 dollars a month in rent
275 i was late almost every single
month uh you know i i got my own little
bird i fly around the world in it's like
it's crazy my life is crazy
and i said dion my life is crazy i said
but what i want to do with the next 20
years of my life is i want to help
create i want to teach people
financial freedom
and he's like man grant you know our
people my people he's like my people he
means
african-american people he's like my
people don't know how to get money
don't know how to keep money and don't
know how to invest money i said yeah you
know what's going to happen
the system is rigged and they're gonna
say what you need to do son is you need
to go to college
you need to borrow some money spend six
years of your life in
what looks like a prison to me
okay 12 years of schools public schools
go back by your little school how many
of you went to school how many of you
went to school
raise your hand if you went to school
okay raise your hand raise your hand if
it helped you
i'm not sure i'm not sure go past by
your little school that you went to when
you were in the 8th grade
the 10th grade and the 12th grade and
you hit me on instagram and say hey
tell me that don't look like a jail to
you
it's not changing conditions for people
would you agree
so so if i got a if i got a 19 year old
kid
that that's a african-american 19 year
old
and i'm like do you need to go to
college to have a chance you need higher
education
to get out of the program oh by the way
that's going to cost you money
you need to borrow money we'll give it
to you two for free
for a while sound like a drug dealer
here
first one's on me first first week's on
me
right
you're being played folks you're being
played
okay now now up to this point you've
been played
after tonight it's on you i don't care
if you're making 300 grand a year i know
people are making 300 grand a year they
have nothing at the end of the year i
know guys that make a million dollars a
year and you're like
bro i can barely breathe i have nothing
left over
i want to talk to you tonight about
freedom how do you get freedom
to do what you want with who you want
as long as you want
and say no to the people that you don't
want to do you you don't want to do and
play with anymore how many of you own
your own business here how many business
owners
okay good how many of you'd like to tell
a customer from time to time you'd like
to say
i need to ask you to leave my office
off the premises take your take your
andrew jackson's
and your lame ass out of here get off my
property okay
please write a yelp review about me then
i kick you out of the place because
it'll be good good
good advertising for us see but you
can't do that what you guys do is you
grovel
no she's like not me so she flips the
other way
she becomes stubborn
no no one is going to tell me what to do
you do that you play that game you'll
end up with nothing too okay
you got to figure out a strategy here
folks you got to figure out a strategy
okay
i just want to bring you back damon
john's going to come up here tonight i
guarantee you my little man
damon call him little man when he gets
here by the way everybody's saying
little man stand up little man
okay i love this guy okay um i'm gonna
tell you where i started you see that
little place right there
that's where i grew up that's where i
275 a month rent those are two doors
guess what that's a duplex
who's been in a duplex before a duplex
somebody lives on the other side charles
whitman was my landlord charles whitman
was also my accounting teacher in
college
the rent was 275 dollars a month the
year was 1978
and i was late half the time dodging
this guy
i took delivery of that a year ago
[Music]
okay right here in opa-locka that's
stupid
okay hey hey put your hands together if
that's ridiculous
no no no put your hands together if
that's ridiculous look
look if you get to meet somebody that
can pay cash for a jet you need to be
like
hug it out with them hard all right okay
look
ridiculous everybody say ridiculous see
that picture right there ridiculous
see this picture right here ridiculous
how many of you sick and ridiculous
do which which side of ridiculous do you
want to play on
what side of ridiculous because your
life is ridiculous right now folks
okay your life is ridiculous every level
of your life
is ridiculous you go to the store you're
paying you're grabbing groceries
for the little freeloading kids okay how
many of you got kids
you how many of you got kids raise your
hand if you got kids okay how many of
you act like a kid
[Music]
you're like man wait a minute man you
give me too much to think about what
should i be doing right now i'm trying
to get you to undo
some of the thinking you got going on
okay the game should be freedom when
you're going to the store
this is not a political issue this is an
economic issue tonight
the date's what july what july 18
2019 let this be the night your life
changes
what have i been thinking man i've been
ridiculous it's been ridiculous
let me see how many levels are
ridiculous in the room how many of you
got cash
in a bank right now raise your hand if
you got cash in the bag
ridiculous
how many of you have a home have a home
you you bought a home
and took a 30-year mortgage out on a
house
raise your hand if you own a home no no
no come on let me hear it let me hear it
let me hear 10x if you
bought a house 10x if you bought a house
that's it six people in the room
you guys are lying to me now buying a
home is ridiculous
how many of you went to college 10x if
you went to college
ridiculous ain't no brain surgeons in
this room
[Music]
what are you sir he's gonna be a surgeon
in a year okay
ridiculous stupid
he could have been a chiropractor he
could have been a masseuse i know my
sisters would make 300 grand a year
do what they want go what they want as
long as they want travel around the
world
like what's the point guys oh well i'm
meant to be a surgeon
my passion is cutting people open
and that and that that that that's what
an accountant i am an accountant
that's what i'm going to do in life dude
good do all that stuff if you want to i
want freedom
i don't care if i got a wrap to get
there catch footballs to get there
cut people to get there i want freedom
okay
and for me being a surgeon cutting
people open when they need to be cut
open
is not going to give me the freedom i
want freedom
go where i want when i want as long as i
want with who i want
and kick people out that i don't want to
play with
it's not about money cash doesn't do
that for you you can put as much paper
as you want your pocket
pablo escobar was not free
[Music]
he was not free he had a cash problem
everybody agree cash killed him
finish this statement if you know what
it is cash is ridiculous
king king now he's learning fast he's
like i don't want cash
cash is how many were taught that cash
is king
who do you think taught you who do you
think ran that mantra
into the american society who the banks
how many believe this the information
you got from that group that you grew up
in that neighborhood that you grew up in
that address
and the beliefs and the thinking of your
moms and dads your pops
your mom's the uncles the ants what
would could could be some of what could
be the issue right now
okay help me out here a penny saved is
a penny earned right how many know that
saying a penny is a penny
okay your mama got real complicated here
a penny
is a penny and if you spend time with
them you'll end up with nothing
freedom how do you get freedom what
would be the easiest way
i could be a rapper man i'm gonna be
kanye i'm gonna try that okay
the chances are negligible to negligible
right i'm gonna be a ball player too
late for me
you're not tall enough right you're not
fast enough and by the way it only lasts
about five or six years
i bought that plane because i learned
how to do this is what we're going to
come back
my team's going to come back in 10 days
and talk to you about how to
invest in real estate real estate not
that you live in
but real estate that pays you to live
wherever you want
there's a specific kind of real estate
in america today that has
created the life that i have today that
allowed me
to buy that jet to put fuel in a plane
to travel
around the world to go to australia for
a month be
be there for a month and none of my
income changes you can't do that with
just a job
i got a watch on right here it is
beyond ridiculous okay you want to look
at that johnny
it's stupid bought two of them the same
week
that's how stupid i was that week but i
didn't pay for it
that paid for it okay i go to work every
day
i bust my ass every day how many in the
room work hard
congratulations say i work hard
no i work hard no no i'm gonna do it
then you do it i work hard
oh damn
come on guys i work hard
[Applause]
look look you got to have energy i'm 60
61 years old i got more energy
than the center part of this room i
don't even know how you guys made it to
the damn event
you should have run out of energy before
you got here i work hard
you're damn right and you need to tell
the whole world you work hard
and you need to work hard and at some
point you got to be like
okay wait a minute i worked hard why am
i going to waste that
when i can invest that
[Music]
what am i doing buying bling
you know what what am i doing saving
money
two ends are the same problem one guy's
hoarding it
frugal mr frugal and another guy is
blowing it
both of them ridiculous everybody agree
okay how many of you got cash in the
bank let me see your hand if you've got
cash in the bank
let me see your hand if you got cash to
make raise your hand goddamn don't don't
tell people you don't have anything
you guys in the back there do you have
any cash in a bank
it's stupid what are you doing
you're making wells fargo and bank
america richer than they already
are what do they do with your money as
soon as they get it what do they do they
lend it to a guy like me
they call me up hey man you want to
borrow some more money we got some fools
in fort lauderdale
over at the diplomat we got some fools
and diplomat man
just giving us their [ __ ] we don't want
it because we know it's going down in
value
so why don't you take it mr c mr gc
mr 365 gc 10x man
why don't you take it and you poured in
some of that real estate
and you keep it for the rest of your
life and you make your family wealthy
long long after you die you understand i
could hit the stage right now and die
and my kids next week
will go to my funeral they burn me up or
whatever they're going to do what you
going to do with me
she'll be like whatever okay
okay whatever that's over with okay and
you know what's gonna happen
she her life doesn't change next week
she doesn't have to sell anything next
week
when my dad died when i was 10 years old
i learned the biggest lesson in my life
my dad was a successful guy hard worker
like most of you in a room
worked hard good guy five kids
52 years old heart blows up in his chest
his two youngest kids were twins
me and my brother gary uh i shared a
womb with one dude
okay i've been sharing with my whole
life i'm tired of sharing
you guys are too serious man do you know
how much fun you can have when you get
rich
dude it's fun man it's funny you got
y'all need some money so you're not
worried about it
you're worried about some of you in a
room are rich and you're still worried
about your money i know people that have
millions of dollars
they're more scared of it than the
people that don't have anything so i'm
here tonight because
my at 61 years old my goal is to help
people get what i've gotten or more
you deserve this you've got to get out
of the grind
this is what i told dion the other night
i want to teach people how to get into
vehicles
that are accessible to them regardless
of your race
your religion your your education level
your age
nobody cares in real estate they don't
care if you're 19
and they don't care if you're 59.
they just care do you want my piece of
property can you buy it
will you close can you get a loan and
we're going to show you how to do all
that all right
who's interested in doing that yes okay
all right
50 years from now this paper might not
even exist on this planet you guys
understand that
you want to take this garbage junk fiat
made up pretend paper and you want to
exchange it for addresses
and bricks and concrete and glass and
steel
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't
have it yet you can get it for free in
the first line of the description below
and if you're enjoying this billionaire
mindset series give me a hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
you have to unbrand yourself from who
you've been
to get to who you want to be a lot of
people may know you for something
they may know you for something they
know you for being this kind of person
being the person who does xyz but maybe
you don't like that anymore maybe you
don't want to be that person anymore
and it might require you to unbrand
yourself that you are no longer this
person
in order for them to start seeing you as
this new person that you want to be this
is a tangent just came to mind but this
is why a lot of people
uh kids have a hard time influencing
their parents
even as adults you know as you as you
are an adult as you grow up and become
an adult you realize
oh your parents didn't actually have
everything figured out they're not the
superheroes you thought they were they
loved you that
but a lot of times they're just doing
the best that they could
but most parents do not want to listen
to their kids for advice for what to do
next
because you've been branded as
the kid not as the person who gives
advice
that's why they don't listen to you it's
why it's really hard to influence your
siblings too because
especially if you're the younger sibling
you've been branded as the little
brother the little daughter
or the little little sister you're not
the one that they listen to for advice
you have to unbrand yourself from that
so when i was talking to matthew
about this on on my interview we'll link
that up at the end of this video
he talked about this long unbranding
phase that he went through
where he stopped doing romantic comedies
where he got offered millions and
millions and millions of dollars to keep
doing romantic comedies but he just
didn't want to be that guy anymore he
did not want to be that guy anymore
and so he turned down every single movie
deal
for 20 months for 20 months
considered retiring considered like
acting isn't for him anymore he's
making you know millions of dollars
doing romantic comedies and just
was tired of it not going to do it
anymore and we'd go back and be a
teacher
that was his backup plan
until things changed he successfully
lost the branding as the romantic comedy
guy and he started getting other
opportunities
and i think it starts as a self-identity
thing
who are you do you believe that you're
still the son
do you believe that you're still just
the brother do you believe that you're
still
just xyz of who you used to be and maybe
that was an identity that was given to
you not one that you have ever even
chose for yourself
it starts with the personal on branding
so for me i used to have a website
people knew me from my website
i had a website i was i was heavily into
seo
search engine optimization we had a
hundred thousand plus pages of content i
had
uh thousands i don't know how many
thousands six thousand eight thousand
something like that people writing for
my website i was i was really good at
getting articles to rank
and i was telling my story and famous
stories
and i just got tired of it i don't know
it just seemed to be a publishing game
there seemed to be less heart in the
content we're making
and just seemed to be about ranking
content as opposed to actually doing
something
so i i got a little bored of that and i
started experimenting with youtube
that's the start of my youtube career i
mean i just started experimenting
just throwing out some videos and they
weren't they weren't fantastic but it
was just an experiment a test
and i liked it so much that i had to
find a way to keep
doing it and i remember the day that i
shut down my website
i i didn't want to sell it because it
was off my name
and i didn't want to sell
iphonecarmichael.com
uh so i decided to close it down
and i shifted my team the people who
were on my team were doing the work for
me
i gave them roles in the youtube side of
my business that was starting to take
off
so nobody you know got laid off or fired
they keep working for me
in a new capacity and it took a while
for the people who were
successful authors some of the authors
on my site had had posted
hundreds of articles i was driving a lot
of business for them
and we shifted it it wasn't just like a
uh
a shutdown right away but we we phased
in maybe it took a
couple of months for the whole thing to
happen and
i was known as the article guy
it's funny because it's been it's been
over 10 years since that
and now i'm known as the youtube guy or
the believe guy
i actually like believe better because
believe could be anything youtube is too
specific to just one platform but
being known as the believe guy now
there's this great video where grant
cardone
on his christmas uh christmas day he's
filming christmas days
he's doing an ig story of him opening up
or his daughter opening up a present or
something or they walked into a hotel
room i forget what it was but
there was believe there and he said
believe you see that evan carmichael
believe
and he tagged me in the story it's like
yeah i'm i'm definitely down with being
known as the believe guy
but that became a conscious unbranding
rebranding
phase where i don't want to just be the
article guy i don't want to be known as
a guy who can get your
content ranked in seo and it's funny now
every now and then i connect with an old
author like i connect with somebody who
was on my site who
who knew me back in those days it's like
yeah i used to post
content on your art on on your website i
wrote articles for your website
that was fun and it's like yeah that was
such a long time ago
i don't really think about those days
much anymore um
it's how quickly i've on on branded
myself
from my own identity if you want to
change where you are then you need to
change who you are
you are a direct result of the
environment that you're in
of the people that you hang out with of
the habits that you do regularly
and of the media and information that
you consume on a regular basis
you are where you are in life because of
your parents because of your friends
because of
the books you are reading or not reading
because of the netflix shows or youtube
channels
that you are watching or not watching
and if you want to change
where you are in life you need to grow
as a human being you need to change
who you are one of the great great great
advantages
of reading is that you get to take
lessons that it may have taken somebody
else decades to learn
and they've consumed it and they've
written it into a book decades sometimes
of research and knowledge
that you can consume in a couple of
hours and immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business
it's a cheat it's a hack
and for a lot of you you may not have a
great circle of friends you may not have
the ability to go out and network with
people you may
live in a tiny town you may have family
that doesn't support you
and so a lot of you will then say well
that's my lot in life and i'm screwed
and i can never change that
no you can change it by reading right by
reading you are hanging
out with people who've done a lot more
than you and the more that you are
hanging around those people even if
they're not in front of you
it'd be amazing to have tony robbins sit
with you every single day and help guide
you through life
but because you can't have that you can
have his books you can learn from him
you can apply all of his lessons into
your life on a daily basis and start
seeing growth
and that applies to any of the authors
that you might look up to
i take this even a step further in that
as my video consumption has gone up
i've read less and less and less i still
read i'm not
happy with how much i'm reading i
probably read a couple of nights a week
i try to make it a daily practice so
it's one of the things that i'm working
on
but i consume a ton of youtube content i
much prefer watching videos
than reading a book that's where my
mindset is at it's why i make videos for
you guys it's why i do
the top 10 series in the mentor me
series especially because
i selflessly me i want to hang around
people
who've done so much more than me and the
more that i'm hanging around those
people
the more their mindsets their way of
thinking their attitudes their belief
seeps into me to allow me to go off and
do bigger things
elon musk and tony robbins and mel
robbins and
e.t and all the people warren buffett
that i profile
i feel like are my friends like these
are my acquaintances these are guys and
ladies that are in my ear constantly
pushing me to do more to strive for
greater things
because the people in my life don't the
people in my life are great and i'm so
fortunate to have
people who are extremely supportive of
everything that i'm doing but nobody's
telling me evan you suck you could be
doing more like what you've done is
great
but i know you could be doing a lot more
and
the amount of growth that i have seen in
the past couple years
i attribute exactly to the video content
that i have consumed and made for you
guys
and i guarantee you whether it's
watching youtube videos like mine
whether it's reading a book a day
you know whether it's consuming just
content that inspires you on a regular
basis
if you were doing that if you made it a
daily habit
a daily practice to consume content
whether that's from a book or video or
friends or conferences or meetups
whatever the thing is
that gets you feeling like you could do
more
you could be greater you could
accomplish bigger things
right if you did that on a daily basis
whatever the thing that made you feel
bold on a daily basis i guarantee you
that your life will be unrecognizable
from where you are in one year from
today
your change will be insane and so
there's that famous quote that says you
are the direct result of the five people
that you spend the most time with
right and that's very true if you look
at the five people who you spend the
most time with they're probably around
the same spot that you are
and so the hack the cheat the shortcut
to get to a better place
is through aspirational mentors it's
through books it's through videos
and so i would encourage you strongly to
really do an
audit of how you are spending your time
what kind of content information you are
consuming on a regular basis
and is that contributing to you on
tapping the inner potential
that you have to go off and do amazing
things and if not
then let's change it you need to tie
your self-worth to the effort
not the results if you tie yourself
forward to the results
to achieving your goals then you'll only
take on things that you think you have a
high chance of winning at
you'll constantly quit on your big goals
and only go after the small ones
tie yourself forward to trying to the
effort
to doing it when it's hard make yourself
proud
with the effort that you put in not just
when you win
but if you keep getting up every day and
put in an
effort that you are proud of you will
win on a level that you never thought
was possible
so i just came back from doing my 90-day
tour 23 cities and one of my goals was
i wanted to stay healthy on my tour one
of my advices
is it's hard for me to stay healthy when
i travel
and that's okay when you're only going
for a day or two or a week at a time i
eat whatever i wanted and then came back
and got back on my healthy journey
but 90 days on the road that's a lot of
time i could do a lot of damage if i ate
like i normally ate
and so i wanted to feel proud of my
effort
of being able to eat healthy and so i
think it's good to take on difficult
things how do you become proud of your
effort you do
things that are difficult to you if it's
easy and you win
you don't care that's not how you build
your self-esteem but when it's
hard and you do it that's when you start
to feel good about yourself that's when
you start to build your pride that's
where you build your self-confidence
and so one of the first stops that we
made along the way
in ohio was at raising canes it's this
famous
chicken place where they told us you
have to go to raising cane you have to
go there
you've got to go you got to try their
fried chicken it's the best in the world
great at the end of my event we went
but it wasn't my cheat day yet eating
healthy i had to pick six days a week it
wasn't my cheat day yet
and so we went and i went in and i
smelled the chicken
and nina and danny my camera guy went in
and they bought it and
i said nina can i can i have your
chicken can i just i just want to hold
it and i want to smell it
and so my mouth is running right now
just thinking about it
i took her chicken instead of staying
home and like you guys go out and eat no
i want to come
i don't want to take the easy path i
want the difficult way i want to be
proud of my effort
so i took the chicken that she had and i
brought it up to my nose and i took a
big
it took a big smell in it was so good my
mouth was watering so much and then they
had this special sauce this dipping
sauce that i took and i
brought it up again smelled it i can
smell it right now and then i give it
back to her
not a single bite here you go enjoy your
chicken
i'm proud of my effort i'm patting
myself on the back i'm doing things that
are difficult
in service of my goals in service of my
ambition but i'm proud of where i am
right now what i'm doing right now and
the small wins along the way i'm proud
of my
effort now that may seem a little bit
crazy
of how to stick to a diet but i think
teaching yourself that you can't be
around bad food
is actually counterproductive you're
teaching yourself that you're not strong
when people say get rid of the junk food
from your house i think you're teaching
yourself that you're not strong that you
can't be around it and then as soon as
you go on vacation
as soon as you go to an office party as
soon as you get out of your house you're
screwed
because you're teaching yourself you
have no tolerance you have no resistance
that you are weak
in this area and so i want to combat
that
i want to be proud of the effort i put
in and gain
strength along the way and so when my
friends are on a diet i tell them the
same thing
a buddy of mine mark drager is on a diet
right now
and he wants to lose an extra 10 pounds
i told him here's what you do
take your favorite food what's your
favorite food and he said cookies
take your favorite food bring it to the
office i want you to be around it
be around the cookies take a smell
and then put it down and tell yourself
that you
are awesome i'm stronger than you
cookies
because you're proud of your effort
because you're trying because you're
doing the difficult things
instead of taking the easy way out and
teaching yourself that you're weak so
how can you be proud of your effort
and start making progress towards your
goals i'm going to give you a three-step
process
on how to do it step number one is pick
a goal that you're having a hard time
with
pick a goal that you're having a hard
time going off and doing not something
easy
not something that's automatic not
something that you're doing every day
that you can just check the box off and
say yeah i did it
when you do the easy things you don't
feel great about yourself it's good it's
a little time you win but it's the
difficult things
what's one goal that you're having a
hard time right now accomplishing
step number two ask how can you make
yourself proud
what can you do today to make progress
on that goal
in a way that makes you proud and that's
different for everybody
what makes me proud might be different
than you but something that you could
take
an action that you can do that would
make you proud of your effort
i gave the same challenge to alex who's
also on a diet alex helps me run toronto
dance salsa
and his advice is big macs so i told him
go to mcdonald's
order a big mac order it he loves a big
mac sauce
open up the case smell it
just smell that extra big mac sauce ask
for the extra big mass sauce so they
have to make it fresh for you
right take it smell it and then go
outside and give it to a homeless person
because he loves acts of service you
smell it you give it to a homeless
person outside
and then you pat yourself on the back
that's what would make him proud
take your goal the one you've been
having a hard time on stop trying to
take the easy way out on it and do
something that makes you proud of your
effort that when you come out of it that
difficult thing
you're gonna say holy cow i'm awesome i
can't believe i was capable of that
and you get up tomorrow you do it again
you do it again you do it again
step number three is share it and
celebrate you just did something amazing
you just did something that you are
proud of share it and celebrate it
whether you want to post it to an
instagram story like mark did
whether you want to just go tell your
friends whether you want to post it on
facebook
tell your best friend tell your parents
celebrate it yourself just celebrate put
on music dance celebrate
you need to celebrate the things that
make you feel proud because when you
celebrate it when you tell people about
it when you keep doing it it'll motivate
you to keep on going
that momentum becomes important that
celebration that sharing
becomes important and i don't think as
entrepreneurs we often
celebrate enough about the effort we may
celebrate the results hey i crossed
a million views hey i got ex-subscribers
hey i won this award
but what you should be celebrating is
the effort of the work you're putting in
when it's hard if you want to sign up
for the entire billionaire mindset
series for free and get the companion
bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there